let's pop in Webheads it's me Mt and
welcome to the heavy spoiler show I'm
super happy to be back collaborating
with the spectacular spoiler man himself
Paul spoilers and yet another super fun
Marvel breakdown and this time let's do
a breakdown of Spider-Man across the
spiderverse shall we this movie is
finally available on digital after all
so we've got to appreciate this
masterpiece of art just one more time
and right away as the opening production
credits roll before the movie even
starts audiences should be able to hear
a mysterious coughing noise this cough
is actually the cough of one of the
Riders slash producers of across the
spider-verse Christopher Miller
producers Christopher Miller and Phil
Lord have been sneaking in Miller's
cough at the beginning of all of their
films since 22 Jump Street which means
the cough has even been included in
their last spider-verse movie as well as
the recent original animated film the
Mitchells versus the machines anyways as
the Sony pictures animation logo starts
to glitch out we can see the logos turn
into the design styles of popular
Spider-Man comics for example this Sony
logo appears to be a reference to Miles
Morales Ultimate Spider-Man comics this
Sony logo looks like a Julia Carpenter
Spider-Woman logo from 1993. this Sony
pictures animation logo looks like an
early Spider-Man comic cover this Sony
pictures animation logo looks like the
cover to Secret Wars number eight and
this Sony pictures animation logo is a
shout out to The Amazing Spider-Man 300
which of course is the first appearance
of Venom a super subtle but nice touch
by the animation team for hardcore comic
book fans to appreciate and just like in
into the spider-verse the movie does not
show us a single moment of action
without letting us know that this movie
has been given the comics code Authority
stamp of approval and for those of you
who don't know the convix code Authority
was established in 1954 to monitor the
quality of comic books being distributed
to impressionable children you know to
make sure that there wasn't an excess of
inappropriate things like horror
violence and Lord to have mercy female
cleavage I mean God forbid a comic book
nerd see the top of a titty in 1954 but
I am so amped that they decided to bring
this little joke back for the top of the
second movie because it really shows
that everybody involved in this movie is
deeply invested in making sure that this
movie feels just as much of a Marvel
comic book in motion like into the
spider-verse was so having this right at
the beginning feels like we're about to
start a whole new comic book issue
filled with little editor's note boxes
scattered throughout and everything but
anyways as Gwen Stacy beats her
frustrations out on the drum set of the
Mary Janes the movie opens up with
visuals of key moments from into the
spider-verse while also showing us quick
glimpses towards future events of this
film you know like Gwen Stacy seeing
Spider-Man 2099 For the First Time
Captain George Stacy pointing a gun in
his daughter Miguel teaching miles about
Canon events miles spying on Gwen while
invisible Gwen using her webs to try to
stop miles Gwen being sent away in the
go home machine and even Gwen spying on
Miles parents at the end of the film but
one super important thing that you might
miss that this intro reveals is that
somebody seemingly used a pair of
tweezers to pick up the spider from
Earth 42 that bit Miles Morales with
that certain somebody being revealed
later on as Dr Jonathan ahm who becomes
miles's main Nemesis the spot as we can
see that same dead Earth 42 spider
amongst the spot's collection of
multiversal mutant spiders in his
apartment later on in the film a
collection that also includes spiders
from Earth 19725 from Spider Girl the
end number one Spider-Man Wars world of
Earth 90214 a different spider from
Penny Parker's Earth 14512 and a spider
from Earth 333 that seemingly escaped
spot's apartment also has a special
multiversal phone number on the side the
number
1917-1610-616 with one of course being
the area code for North America 917
being the area code for New York City
and 1610 and 616 being a reference to
miles's home Universe of 1610 and Peter
B Parker's 616 Universe anyways the
movie begins with us on Earth 65's
version of Chelsea New York with the 65
and Earth 65 being a direct reference to
the year 1965 which is the year Gwen
Stacy first appeared in Marvel Comics
and The Amazing Spider-Man number 31.
When Stacy engages in and enrages at
band practice with her soon-to-be former
band The Mary Janes consisting of three
major women in Peter Parker's life in
the comics Mary Jane Watson on vocals
Betty Brandt on piano and Gloria Grant
on guitar both Betty and Gloria have
both worked as Jamison secretaries at
The Daily Bugle in the main Spider-Man
comics but all four of them appear to be
practicing for a concert inside of a
Visions Academy Auditorium as a sports
Banner from the 90s can be seen hanging
in the background but I especially love
how one of Gwen's bandmates calls Gwen
deaf leopard like d-e-a-f deaf as Gwen
absent-mindedly he drums her feelings
away because not only is this a
reference to a 1970s Rock Band Def
Leppard but it is exactly what one of
Gwen's band mates says when Gwen first
is introduced in her first appearance in
2014's edge of the spider verse number
two this exact same thing happens with
Gwen and her band in the opening of that
issue just like it does in the opening
of across the spider-verse including
Gwen experiencing flashbacks as she
drums I really did think that starting
spider-verse 2 with a tribute to
spider-gwen's first comic was extremely
clever here but I personally have a
special attachment to Earth 65
specifically because of the art style of
this universe and how this specific
watercolor art style is how I personally
first got into comics in 2015. artist
Robbie Rodriguez's incredible cover art
for a spiderwen's first solo issues are
what led me to buy my first ever Marvel
comic as an adult and those very
spider-gwen Comics are what fostered my
deep love of comic books today so
getting to witness across the
spider-verse bring Rodriguez's art to
life for Earth 65's watercolor aesthetic
has been deeply satisfying to me as a
comic book YouTuber today especially how
this movie likes to use red for people
in Gwen's life that she grows resentment
towards like the movie does first with
the Mary Janes when Gwen gets mad at
them and then soon after with Captain
Stacy when they get into an argument all
while Gwen is painted in a blue hue to
represent how Gwen's inner feelings of
loneliness and powerlessness are fueling
her cold nature towards the people that
she loves and I really do appreciate
that Splash and bleed of purple when
Gwen gives her dad a hug right before he
heads off to confront the vulture at the
Guggenheim because it shows those two
conflicting colors coming together but
anyways as Gwen experiences a flashback
to a Stacy family dinner with her
version of Peter Parker we can see
Captain George Stacy and Peter Parker
disagree on their opinions of the masked
spider vigilante of New York which Bears
a lot of similarities to when Andrew
Garfield Spider-Man had a family dinner
disagreement with Captain Stacy in The
Amazing Spider-Man 1. but as the
flashback continues we can see that an
earth 65 variant of Ned leads bullies
Peter Parker which then pushes Peter to
want to become a strong superhuman like
Gwen by taking the lizard serum which
strongly mirrors what happens to Earth
6-5 Peter Parker during spider-gwen's
origin story in the edge of the spider
verse number two but also if you think
about it knowing that Ned leads is what
causes Peter Parker to turn into the
lizard and be killed it's a lot
different after MCU Ned leads made that
promise to never hurt Peter in
Spider-Man no way home however with Ned
Leeds comic book history as the
Hobgoblin him being at odds with Peter
Parker seems more likely than not in the
grand scheme of the Multiverse I also
found it quite sad how Peter Parker knew
when was Spider-Woman and wanted to see
her face before he died because it
reminded me a lot of the same pain
Insomniac Spider-Man had to face when
Aunt May wanted to see his face before
she died but anyways as news reels of
Captain George Stacy hunting down Spider
Woman begin to play we can hear here JK
Simmons returning to his role as J Jonah
Jameson once again making this Earth 65
variant the third version of Jameson JK
Simmons has played in his film career
which is quite crazy and when Gwen gets
home and has her first tense moment with
her dad in her bedroom you can see a
tiny little frame in her room that says
need more Punk which both acts as a way
for Gwen to express her love for punk
rock but also as a clever piece of
foreshadowing to how she will inevitably
run away from home to live with spider
Punk for a short while Gwen also has a
poster that says protects trans kids in
her room which is deeply reflective of
Gwen's responsible and compassionate
personality while also being very
thematically fitting as the colors of
the trans flag match the three main
bright colors of spider-gwen's suit also
if you look at George Stacy's shirt you
can see that he's wearing a very large
and Faded Visions Academy gymnastic
shirt which I thought was a really nice
way to show how deeply George Stacy
loves his daughter and supports her
Hobbies like gymnastics a hobby that we
see in full effect as Gwen gracefully
swings over to confront a vulture from a
Leonardo da Vinci Style universe by the
name of Adriano tumino the Italian
Renaissance version of Adrian tombs this
alternate universe vultures art style
was apparently deeply inspired by the
15th century artwork within Leonardo da
Vinci's codex atlanticus and considering
how Adrian tombs has always had a love
for inventing in the comics a da Vinci
vulture variant is an insanely clever
design choice in my opinion Adriana
tumino of course looks drastically
different from the vulture native to
earth65 who we can see Captain George
Stacy glancing at a file of before he
enters the Guggenheim Museum the Adrian
tombs pictured in the fire looks like a
faithful Recreation of the earth65
Adrian tombs from the comics the very
first villain that spidergram faces off
against in her first solo series and a
little later we learned from Spider-Man
2099 Miguel O'Hara that this Renaissance
vulture variant only showed up in
earth65 in large part to Gwen and Miles
Morales actions at the alchemax super
glider at the end of into the
spider-verse as that explosion has
caused sizable tears within the
spiderverse that random Spider-Man
characters and villains started falling
into and seeing as Miguel directly
mentions MCU Spider-Man and Doctor
Strange by name soon after he blames
Gwen and miles for tearing the holes in
the spider-verse it's looking very
likely to me that this Renaissance Da
Vinci vulture along with the other
spider Society prisoners like MCU
Prowler probably fell in one of the
super collider holes during their return
trip following Doctor Strange's final no
way home spell this would also explain
why MCU vulture is now in Sony's Venom
universe as well it seems like the
multiversal consequences of both
Spider-Man no way home and Spider-Man
into the spider-verse working together
is what is causing all of this Mayhem
that Miguel is super annoyed about but
speaking of Miguel let's talk about
Spider-Man 2099 the spider that Gwen
refers to as the blue panther the Caped
blue seder dark Garfield and Macho Libre
which are references to Black Panther
the Caped Crusader Garfield the cats and
Jack Black's Nacho Libre because he
looks like a wrestler a spider who
enters the scene with a cape that he
only likes to put on for dramatic effect
but no seriously why even have the cape
if you are never going to wear it but
anyways in the comics Miguel O'Hara gets
his spider powers in a very unique way
compared to spiders like Peter Parker or
Miles Morales in Miguel's first
appearance in 1992's Spider-Man 2099
number one we learned that Miguel O'Hara
is a wildly intelligent genetic
scientist who is working at alcamax when
one of his angry co-workers tried to
kill him by overloading a machine meant
to graft spider DNA onto human DNA and
because of this Miguel developed the
proportional strength and Agility of a
spider along with crazy sharp teeth and
retractable Talons on his fingers and
toes features that we see best when
Miguel is about to take a massive bite
out of the vulture's face in front of a
bunch of witnesses I really do love this
Frame of Miguel bearing his teeth at
vulture as it appears to be a direct
reference to the final page of his first
appearance in the comics so having him
bare his teeth during his first
appearance in the movie was super
fitting however one thing that most
viewers don't really consider is how
much Miguel's Proficiency in the field
of genetics and technology is the main
reason why he was the one to form spider
society and no one else because as we
learn in into the spider-verse one of
the key components needed to be able to
find other variants throughout the
Multiverse is that person's DNA so just
like Kingpin and Dr Octavius use DNA
from his dead wife and son to try to
find variants of them Miguel O'Hara used
his genetic and technological know-how
to develop all the spider-verse watches
for spider society as well as the creepy
go home machine that would inevitably
send Miles Morales to Earth 42 by
locking onto his spider's genetic
signature Miguel is also able to shoot
organic webbing out of his wrist in the
comics much like Tobey Maguire
Spider-Man can however and across the
spider verse it appears that he mainly
uses a futuristic web shooter from the
year 2099. futuristic webs that
apparently can zigzag towards their
target much like darkseid's Omega beams
however one of the most important things
that separates Spider-Man 2099 from
other spiders in the spider-verse is
that while his reflexes and eyesight are
indeed insane Miguel O'Hara does not
possess a cosmic spider sense as we can
see demonstrated when Miguel doesn't see
vultures attack from behind coming While
spider-gwen most certainly did if I were
to guess Miguel's lack of a Spider Sense
is likely tied to him not being directly
bitten by a spider during his origin
there appears to be a difference between
getting spiral DNA via a machine versus
getting mutated spider DNA directly from
a spider bite however we can't talk
about Spider-Man 2099 without talking
about his handy dandy AI assistant Lila
who much like Miguel is returning to the
spider-verse franchise since the last
time we saw her pop up in the
post-credits scene Lila's name is
actually an acronym that stands for
light rate life form approximation as
that is the type of futuristic AI that
Lila is in the comics and much like
Cortana helps out Master Chief in the
HALO Series Lila is Miguel's AI
companion as he goes throughout his hero
business throughout the Multiverse and
though Lila's movie design drastically
differs from her Marilyn Monroe inspired
designs in the comics she does appear to
share her comic Lila's very human-like
personality despite being an AI and we
can see movie Lila's unique personality
shine best as she teases Miguel into
admitting that he needs backup before
revealing that she went behind his back
and called for backup anyway so Lila
appears to have a special autonomy that
most fictional AI do not have but
actually fun facts about that specific
moment between Lila and Miguel because
apparently a bunch of eagle-eyed
spider-verse fans on the internet
discovered that Lila uses completely
different animations to tease Miguel
depending on what version of the movie
that you're watching for example one
version of the movie has Lyla taking a
selfie using a bunny ears filter on
Miguel and another version has her
teasing him without a virtual phone to
fit the Multiverse theme of the movie it
appears that Sony Pictures have released
a number of very slightly different
versions of across the spider-verse to
theaters the differences are super
subtle but spectacular Spider heads like
Reddit user ho ho ho you have compiled a
list of all of those differences that we
will briefly flash on the screen now
take it in take it in good you're doing
the spider Lord's work you ho ho ho you
but anyways when backup finally arrives
it comes in the form of a very pregnant
Jessica Drew Spider Woman as played by
insecures Issa Rae a version of
Spider-Woman that Gwen Stacy looks up to
a lot like Miles Morales looked up to
both versions of Peter Parker and into
the spider-verse and though the
character of Jessica Drew was first
introduced as Spider Woman in 1977's
Marvel 2 and 1 number 29 her design
appears to be heavily inspired by
Marvel's actual first Spider Woman
Valerie the librarian who dawned the
Spider Woman mantle three year years
before Jessica Drew in 1974's Spidey
super stories number one fighter Women's
Pregnancy in the movie is of course
inspired by Dennis halem's iconic Spider
Woman run in 2015 where Jessica Drew
fights crime while Mega preggers
including a pregnant Spider Woman and
across the spider-verse was a phenomenal
way for this movie to drive home the
main theme of the series that anybody
can wear the mask no matter what your
circumstances may be like one of the
best things about across the spider
verse is how it is one big celebration
of diversity so having a black and
Pregnant Spider Woman is spectacular
representation for people who can
identify with one or both of these
experiences because strong black and or
pregnant women are a rare sight to see
leading a comic book movie on the big
screen but anyways after Gwen Miguel and
Jess stop Leonardo de vultures Rampage
while also saving a museum goer who is
dressed like the Riddler for some reason
Gwen reveals her secret identity to her
father before being recruited to join
Miguel's Multiverse spider team very
much mirroring spiderwen's identity
revealed to Captain Stacy in edge of the
spider verse number two right before
spider UK recruits her to join the
original spider-verse team also remember
how I was talking about this movie's use
of blue and red in relation to
spider-gwen and the people that she
fights with notice how Captain Stacy is
half red and half blue as he begins to
struggle with his sense of Duty I
believe they gave Captain Stacy that
blue tint to show that he's beginning to
understand his daughter's perspective
and why Gwen has been acting so
strangely like this movie's use of the
art of the various universes to convey
emotion is Second To None like when the
paint in the background appears to cry
and bleed as Gwen emotionally reacts to
having her father point a gun at her
face and frame her for having a weapon
that she didn't have but anyways after
Gwen disappears into the portal we are
then finally brought to Miles Morales
native home of Earth 1610 Brooklyn on
Tuesday July 11 2023 judging by the date
on the convenience store security camera
anyway and as of this point it has been
a full two years since the events of the
first film meaning that Miles has a good
amount of experience as Spider-Man under
his belt as we can see him punching
Hammerhead a black frog man which is
amazing Beetle and grizzly in a
flashback sequence that happened much
before miles fateful trip to the
convenience store convenience store
being robbed by the scientists formerly
known as Dr Jonathan Ahn the spot the
main antagonist of the movie introducing
the pages of 1985's spectacular
Spider-Man 98 the spot has been one of
the most ridiculous looking and
underrated Spider-Man villains of all
time so ridiculous that Peter Parker's
first reaction when meeting him was to
laugh his spider-themed ass off and mock
him much like Miles Morales does when
they first face off inside that
convenience store a mocking that the
spot deeply takes to heart while
plotting his revenge against miles we
learn later in the movie that Dr
Jonathan on was fired from his job at
Alco Max after his body was covered in a
bunch of black dark matter spots as a
direct consequence to Miles blowing up
the super collider at the end of into
the spider-verse judging by his super
mess apartment that Gwen visits later on
in the movie I can definitely understand
why the spot is super pissed at Miles
Morales because it seems like he truly
loved his job as a dark matter scientist
at Alco Max and was sort of excelling at
it as evidenced by his Alco Max award
for the Breakthrough of the year in fact
according to Justin K Thompson one of
the directors of across the spider-verse
alongside Ken powers and Joachim dos
Santos the very science of the
supercollider was actually all doctor on
because Jonathan was always obsessed
with the idea of mastering the mysteries
of dark matter to travel the Multiverse
the very same concept that Miles Morales
brings up while talking about Princeton
University's science program to his
parents during their meeting with the
guidance counselor Princeton has the
best quantum researchers in the country
they're moving electrons across
dimensional thresholds I mean they're
studying Dark Matter like miles's deep
desire to see Gwen Peter and the rest of
his spider-verse friends again was
driving his desire to go to Princeton
miles wanted to unlock the secrets of
Multiverse travel by studying dark
matter and quantum physics just like
Jonathan on did honestly if miles and
Jonathan met in another life or Another
Universe miles would probably look up to
Jonathan a lot much like both Sam Raimi
and Playstation versions of Peter Parker
once revered Dr Octavius in fact if we
study the incredible art design that
across the spider-verse artist Tiffany
lamb did with spot's apartment we can
see that Jonathan's obsession with using
dark matter to travel the Multiverse led
him to essentially recreate an entire
laboratory within this tiny space in his
apartment an apartment filled with books
on Dark Matter String Theory the
Multiverse black holes gravity and
Quantum math and stuff however speaking
of duck awk despite having done most of
the Breakthrough science by himself
Jonathan had all of his passionate dark
matter science stolen by Dr Olivia
Octavius who then took most of the
credit for the collider's creation while
leaving Jonathan to fade into the
background of Alco Max scientists just
waiting to be hit with a bagel by a
confused teenager however while spot is
talking to himself while building this
mini super collider in his apartment he
mentions needing a little bit more dark
energy which is a really important piece
of Science in both our real life and the
MCU in fact it is a concept directly
linked to the blue space traveling
cosmic energy of the Tesseract a bunch
of MCU scientists like Dr Selvig were
all studying how to unlock the secrets
of dark energy under Nick Fury at the
dark energy Mission facility at the
beginning of Avengers 1. and since the
end of Marvel Studios what if Episode 1
revealed that the dark energy within the
Tesseract is directly linked to
multiversal travel it would definitely
make sense that dark energy would be
needed to make any multiversal super
Collider work anyways after miles jumps
into the portal after Gwen we of course
find ourselves in mumbatin on Earth 5101
the home of pavitra prabhakar AKA
Spider-Man India a character first
introduced in 2005 Spider-Man India
number one in the movie Earth 5101 is a
mishmash of India's Mumbai in New York's
Manhattan with an art style that matches
the art found in the Indra gel Comics
popular in India in the 1970s with the
Phantom being one of their most popular
comics and much like Peter Parker has a
relationship with Gwen Stacy the
daughter of police captain Stacy in many
universes movie Predator has a
relationship with Gayatri Singh the
daughter of police captain Singh in this
universe and while Spider-Man India has
only been Spider-Man for around 6 months
he apparently has already been invited
to join spider society and has quickly
developed a strong kinship with the
rebellious Hobie Brown the anarchic
Spider-Man himself known as Spider Punk
the single most interesting character in
this beautiful movie filled with
interesting characters one of my
absolute favorite things about spider
Punk's design in this movie is how he
appears to change color based on his
mood with Hobie being fully colored and
bright when he's experiencing happiness
love and satisfaction like when he hangs
out with Gwen and pravitter while losing
his color completely and turning black
and white as he starts to to experience
darker and more negative emotions like
anger disappointment and frustration
like what happens when Hobie is around
Miguel or when Hobie is on the elevator
annoyed with miles for wanting to even
meet Miguel but anyways though spider
Punk does hail from Earth 138 in the
comics the original character of Holby
Brown was actually first introduced in
comic book Earth 616 as Marvel comics's
first iteration of the prowler in the
pages of 1969's Amazing Spider-Man 78.
Marvel then took the character of Hobie
Brown and made the alternate universe
spider punk in 2014 though it would seem
that across the spiderverse has
purposely left the Earth number for
spider Punk's World a mystery for now as
a lot of information about spider Punk's
Earth seems to be being saved for beyond
the spiderverse for some reason but we
can still definitely see that spider
Punk's world is inspired by the London
punk rock scene of the 70s and 80s mixed
in with some New York City Flair however
one of the few things that we know about
Hobie Brown's time in this universe is
that he has no love for the oppressive
Kingpin and according to spider-verse 2
director Ken Powers spider Punk lives on
a canal boat that also doubles as Spider
Punk's secret spider headquarters
however one of the most surprising
things about spider Punk and across the
spider-verse is that he appears to share
a bioelectric power set very similar to
Miles Morales as we can see an older and
more experienced spider Punk coaching
miles on how to use his whole Palm
instead of just his fingertips to
disable force fields twice over the
course of this movie it appears the
implication is that spider Punk was
likely bitten by a variant of the same
spider that bit Miles Morales and his
bioelectric powers are the main reason
why spider Punk is able to shred an
electric guitar without a power source
the electricity running throughout his
body is where his guitar is getting all
of that juice I thought was a really
nice creative decision however I truly
do believe that there is a deeper
meaning here behind miles using his
fingertips versus Hobie Brown using his
whole entire hand as I believe it is
meant to symbolize the drastically
different approaches that both miles and
spider Punk have with how how they wield
their great power and these two
drastically different approaches could
potentially become a major factor in
beyond the spiderverse miles choosing to
have a more delicate and reserved
bioelectric touch in comparison spider
Punk's more aggressive and destructive
application of his powers illustrates
just how much force each of these people
are willing to use for what they see as
the greater good miles practices
restraints while Hobie is not afraid to
aggressively and emotionally use his
whole hand to create the reality that he
wants to see and it's these differences
that fuels both miles and hobie's
character dynamic in the film as Hobie
spends a good chunk of his time on
screen trying to convince miles to not
enlist in Spider-Man 2099 spider Army
and simply judging by how much Miguel
and Hobie just don't get along you can
tell just how much Hobie hates
everything about Miguel's oppressive
Cosmic cops who love to police the
spider-verse just like the TVA police
the sacred timeline in Loki with
Spider-Man 2099 even whipping out the
same m Su inspired multiversal imagery
while explaining the structure of the
spider-verse to Miles you can definitely
tell the Marvel Studios and Sony have a
deeper relationship than ever before and
this is why in my opinion that spider
Punk will most likely end up becoming
the most dangerous person to the
spider-verse as we know it in the sequel
to this film because the very concept of
Canon events and making sure human
beings suffer and die just to fulfill
some mysterious entities Grand Cosmic
plan for the Multiverse is something
that spider Punk cannot and will not
stand for much like Sylvie plotted to
take down the Mastermind behind the TVA
as soon as she learned that the TVA
existed spider Punk has likely been
plotting the same exact thing and has
even manipulated Gwen Stacy into
Gathering a spider Army by the end of
the film to rise up against Miguel in
his authoritarian regime because that is
what spider Punk does best he knows how
to build a good army and because the
title of this next film is called beyond
the spiderverse I can also see spider
Punk going beyond the spiderverse to the
very end of time itself fine whatever
mysterious great Weaver is weaving
everyone's Fates like a dictator and
then killing them just like Sylvie kills
he who remains for doing the exact same
thing because ever since we learned
about spider punk in 2015 spider-verse
number two Hobie Brown has always been
willing to kill in the name of Anarchy
spider Punk is a version of Spider-Man
whose sense of responsibility is deeply
rooted in his dream of freedom for all
and he is more than willing to do
whatever it takes to dismantle any
oppressive system hell at the end of
that same issue Hobie Brown can be seen
publicly executing president Osborne
with his guitar like Hobie Brown is
built different and that is the reason
why the superior Spider-Man audio
Octavius wanted to recruit him as part
of his spider Army he is 100 not afraid
to kill for what he believes is the
greater good Colby Brown killing the
great Weaver at the end of time would be
a fantastic way to end the spider-verse
trilogy in preparation to cross over
with the MCU because if both Sony
spider-verse and Marvel Studios a sacred
timeline start branching out control the
chances of these two separate
multiverses overgrowing and branching
into one another to stabilize both
multiverses Rises significantly which
would then of course lead to MCU
incursions with the spiderverse paving
the road to Secret Wars with Multiverse
Mayhem that's right y'all I said two
separate multiverses as of across the
spider-verse it is now officially
confirmed that the Marvel Cosmos
including the Marvel Cinematic Universe
is all part of one poly Multiverse as
evidenced by Spider-Man 2099 referring
to the spider-verse as the
arachnohumanoid poly Multiverse with
Paulie of course meaning many this is
why Loki gets sent to a completely
different TVA at the end of Loki season
1 and also why there is no TVA in Sony's
spider-verse movies the spider-verse
appears to be Sony's own unique
Multiverse of possibilities a Multiverse
that used to be completely separate from
the MCU until MCU Peter Parker and
Doctor Strange goofed up big time and
brought a bunch of souls from the spider
servers to the MCU Multiverse at the
very beginning of Spider-Man no way home
Doctor Strange tried to send all those
anomalies back to their native
spider-verse Multiverse with that last
memory spell but it appears that that
spell didn't just send those
spider-verse souls in the sky back to
the spider-verse but also accidentally
sent MCU native Spider-Man characters
like Michael Keaton's vulture and Donald
Glover's Prowler to the spider verse 2.
then all of those Souls from both
multiverses started falling into the
tares in reality that Miles and the Gang
made at the end of into the spider-verse
so it looks like not everyone made it
back to their native reality which is
why Spider-Man 29 has a massive prison
of anomalies that he's trying to sort
back to their native worlds anomalies
including PlayStation insomniac's
version of Spider-Man from Earth 1048
standing right behind a green pixelated
Atari version of Green Goblin on the
right and the blue pixelated video man
on the left video man made his debut in
Spider-Man and his amazing friends and
had the ability to bring characters from
video video games to life which could
possibly be the reason how Insomniac
Spider-Man got there in the first place
since we do know that PlayStation
Spider-Man games actively exist within
the spiderverse as miles's roommate
Genki Lee can be seen playing Spider-Man
PS5 at the start of the film but anyways
right before miles and Grand meet up
with Miguel they of course run into
Margot Cass the spider bite of Earth
22191 a universe introduced in 2018's
Balto spiders number one where everyone
spends most of their time in a virtual
reality cyberspace much like in Ready
Player One spider bite fights crime in
this virtual cyberspace with her own
virtual Avatar though Margo and Miles do
appear to share a mysterious Cosmic
spider bomb that we don't really know
about quite yet as both their spider
senses appear to have this weird
connection with each other as they first
meet but this is before miles inevitably
catches up with his former Mentor Peter
B Parker of Sony spiderverse 616 along
with his new baby daughter Mayday Parker
a baby who has manifested her spider
powers within six months of her birth
and even has a fully developed Spider
Sense which is drastically different
than her comic book counterpart as comic
Mayday Parker who was introduced in
1997's what if 105 did not gain her
powers until she was a teenager but
anyways after the gang catches up
Spider-Man 2099 schools Miles Morales
and Canon events 101 and Miles learns
that some mysterious force in the cosmos
has written the stories of all the
spiders of the spider-verse and that
every spider must have certain
unchangeable events happen in their
lives in order for them to become the
heroes they were meant to be for example
the Canon event that Miguel refers to as
ASM 90 dictates that a police captain
close to a spider hero has to die trying
to save an innocent life with ASM 90 of
course referring to 1970s Amazing
Spider-Man 90 which featured the death
of police captain Stacy this is why we
see images of both Josh Keaton's
Spectacular Spider-Man and Andrew
Garfield's Amazing Spider-Man both
grieving over the loss of their
respective Captain Stacy's but while we
have seen Andrew Garfield grieve over
Dennis Leary's George Stacy before in
the first Amazing Spider-Man the death
of Clancy Brown's George Stacy from The
Spectacular Spider-Man cartoon was
revealed for the first time in across
the spiderverse if other Canon events
follow the same asm-90 trend of being
named after Spider-Man comics the
Spider-Man no more Canon event that
spider Punk is looking at would be ASM
50 after The Amazing Spider-Man 50 a
Spider Woman being trapped under wobble
would be ASM 33 a Spider-Man getting
married to the love of their life would
be Asma 21 after The Amazing Spider-Man
Annual 21 and the Uncle Ben death Cannon
event would be af-15 for Amazing Fantasy
15 which is of course Spider-Man's first
ever appearance and while the Uncle Ben
Cannon event plays out for Miles we can
see Tobey Maguire Peter Parker from Sam
raimi's first Spider-Man film grieve
over the loss of Uncle Ben next to
images of The Spectacular Spider-Man and
the video game version of Andrew
Garfield's Amazing Spider-Man grieving
over Uncle Ben as well but anyways it is
when miles starts to reject the spider
Society by running away that the real
fun begins because that is when we truly
get to see all the incredible diversity
that spider Society has to offer there
are so many different types of spider
people in this movie with most of them
being completely original Creations for
the film but while close to 100 of these
variants are completely new there are a
lot of familiar faces that Spider-Man
fans from different mediums will
recognize familiar faces like fan
favorite Ben Reilly the Scarlet Spider
voiced by Andy Sandberg who first
appeared in The Amazing Spider-Man 149
then we have Spider-Man Unlimited from
the 1999 cartoon of the same name the
bombastic Bag Man Who first appeared in
The Amazing Spider-Man 258 Charlotte
Weber the sun spider from 2019 spider
verse number three werewolf Spider-Man
from 2007's Marvel Zombies Army of
Darkness number five web man from Spidey
super stories number 25 Spider-Man 2211
Max born from 1995 Spider-Man 2099 meets
Spider-Man number one flash Thompson's
Captain spider from 1977's what if
number seven Lego Spider-Man from Lego
Marvel Superheroes lady spider from 24th
teen spiderverse Number One Auto
Octavius superior Spider-Man who
actually became Spider-Man in Spider-Man
697 a cyborg Spider-Woman based off
cyborg Spider-Man who debuted in 2014
Superior Spider-Man number 33 a Metro
boom in Spider-Man voiced by rap
producer Metro Boomin who also helped
produce the spider-verse 2 soundtrack
Peter parked Carr from 2015's Amazing
Spider-Man number 12. Julia Carpenter
Spider-Woman from 1984 Secret Wars
number seven Mary Jane Watson spinaret
who first adopts the title in 2016's
Spider-Man renew your vows number two is
walking alongside her daughter Anna Mae
Parker who becomes the spiderling in
2017's renew your vows number four then
we have web Slinger from 2014's Amazing
Spider-Man number 9 riding Widow the
spider horse from 2015's Amazing
Spider-Man number 12. we also got last
and Spider-Man from 2003 Spider-Man 58
manga vs Spider-Man from Marvel manga vs
Spider-Man number one spider side from
Spider-Man 399 and we also got spider
cop a Persona that Insomniac Spider-Man
invented and as an inside joke with a
police officer makes an appearance after
being made canon in 2018 spider Gannon
number four but there is also a spider
cop very prevalent in the earth X Series
as well we can also see spider Rex from
2022's Edge of the spider verse number
one spider monkey from Spider-Man family
number one fighter cat from spider
Island I love New York City number one
the original animated Spider-Man from
1967 who Miguel first recruited in the
into the spider-verse post-credits scene
the silver Mark 1 armored Spider-Man
from web of Spider-Man number 100 a
black mark II Spider-Man from Spider-Man
656 and a red and black Mark III
Spider-Man from Spider-Man 682 and of
course the entire spider gang from the
first movie whose spidergram recruits as
part of the spider Society resistance at
the very end of the film with Penny
Parker of course getting a new spider
Mech that has a much closer resemblance
to the mech from her first appearance in
2014's edge of the spider verse number
five and they are of course joined by
newcomers Spider-Man India spider bite
and the instigator of the hour spider
Punk who is the reason why this Army
assembled in the first place and
together they all hope to rescue Miles
Morales from Earth 42 an earth that was
robbed of their Spider-Man because
alchemax sent that spider to Earth 1610
after Miguel's go home machine sent
miles to Earth 42 after that machine
locked onto the Earth 42 spider DNA in
Miles blood miles meets Earth 42 uncle
Aaron along with his nephew miles G
Morales this universe's newest iteration
of the prowler following in the
footsteps of Uncle Aaron can actually
see the back of Mile G morales's head at
the beginning of the film as he sits in
class almost about to be bitten by the
radioactive spider of Earth 42 a spot
reveals the spider's origin to Miles
according to director Justin K Thompson
it is because miles Gonzalo Morales was
never bit and became a superhero that
the Sinister Six of Earth 42 have
completely corrupted and taken over
Society then forcing uncle Aaron and
Miles G Morales to become hardened
Heroes as they fight for the innocent of
their New York City like Robin Hood Type
Prowlers so the start of beyond the
spiderverse will likely see Earth 1610
Miles Morales team up with both miles
gibrales and Aaron Davis Prowlers to
address some of that crime together but
anyways that is it for this breakdown of
Spider-Man across the spider-verse these
animated films are literally Second To
None So I want to thank Mr Paul's
spoilers once again for giving me the
opportunity to break this film down for
all of you today you're an awesome man
Paul and I love you very much if you
want even more Marvel insight and
research for my goofy brown ass
subscribe to youtube.com massretainment
today or you can follow me at
massertainment on Twitter or Instagram
or wherever I am on the internet because
that is my name but most importantly do
not forget to subscribe to heavy
spoilers right now Paul is always
cranking up some high quality content
and you do not want to miss a single
second of it so when you hit subscribe
make sure you hit that Bell so you can
get all the notifications every time
Paul uploads a video don't you miss out
now hit that Bell again thank you guys
so much for watching this video I love
you guys so much and I'll see you guys
next time bye